For as long as I can remember, I've had a
pet. It's no wonder I'm such a social butterfly.
[MUSIC]
Hi guys, I'm Catie Wayne filling in for Laci
Green on DNews. Come back Laci, I miss you.
According to a new study, young adults with
loving relationships with their pets have
stronger social relationships as well as a
healthy connection with their communities.
Over 500 participants aged 18-26 were surveyed
about their relationships with animals. Their
responses were recorded against answers they
gave to questions regarding the progress of
their positive youth development characteristics.
These include competence, caring, confidence,
connection, and character (alliteration for
the win). They were also surveyed about feelings
of depression.
They found that those who cared for animals
also engaged in "contribution" activities
like community service, demonstrating leadership,
and helping friends and family, much more
so than those who gave zero cares about an
animal. The more they cared about their pet,
the higher the contribution scores.
However, it is important to know that just
because one owns an animal does not mean one
is going to be more socially savvy. It takes
the loves and cares.
Developmental Psychologist and research assistant
professor at the Cummings School of Veterinary
Medicine at Tufts University (that's a wordy
title) Megan Mueller said that the "findings
suggest that it may not be whether an animal
is present in an individual's life that is
most significant but rather the quality of
the relationship." "The young adults in the
study who had strong attachment to pets reported
feeling more connected to their communities
and relationships."
While this is interesting, it kind of makes
sense. When you are able to develop an emotional
bond and attachment to an animal, it seems
a little obvious that your ability to empathize
and connect with other PEOPLE would correlate
positively.
But, more research must be done. Mueller said,
while "we can't draw causal links with this
study" "it is a promising starting point to
better understanding the role of animals in
our lives, especially when we are young."
I personally didn't need another reason to
love my pets, but now I can be all scientific
and schtuff and be like "yeah, i love my pets,
and the more i love my pets the more i contribute
to society in a positive way so get off my
back i love animals okay?"
Tell me about your first pet in the comments
below! I want to know all of the things: what
kind of animal was it? Name? How old were
you? etc. Be sure to like this video and subscribe
to DNews and if you're feeling generous, check
me out over on Animalist News as well as my
new channel Weird, Gross, and Beautiful! Love
you guys, bye!